[Music]  happy b-day Beyonce turns 36 Queen be  celebrated her special day with friends  and family at the made in America  festival in Philadelphia Pennsylvania  over the holiday weekend and was wished  an epic happy birthday with this post on  her website some of yon says famous  friends including former First Lady  Michelle Obama  tennis pro Serena Williams and Destiny's  Child members Kelly Rowland and Michelle  Williams even mom Tina Knowles Lawson  and Beyonce's daughter Blue Ivy were in  on the fun  dressing up in formation fashion paying  tribute to the birthday girl and helping  raise money for the victims of Hurricane  Harvey Adele also sent her love to the  lemonade singer tweeting happy birthday  to the Queen we love you like no other  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you